[Music]
May is stroke awareness month and
according to the CDC every 40 seconds
someone in the U.S has a stroke 8 news
now reporter Brian Wills spoke to a
recent stroke survivor here in Las Vegas
and he tells us how he survived this
medical emergency with limited
consequences
you really never thought it would happen
to me Richard Aguila had recently turned
51 when the blood flow to his brain was
blocked also known as a stroke the whole
left side of my body just
became numb he knew what it was due to
his wife being a nurse she rushed him to
the hospital when you get to ER you
don't hesitate I'm having a stroke
just yell it out or I'm having a heart
attack and so that's that's the reason
why they tended to me so quickly while
he was being treated with medications to
fight blood clots he fought to keep his
strength I was fighting to to kind of
you know just simple things just close
your hand open it back up
you know make sure your leg doesn't fall
asleep Richard is grateful to be alive
after that experience and it's thankful
to be back here working although he has
eased up on the pace a little bit to
take a little more stress out of his
life get back up
and try to do the things that you used
to do slowly it's been nearly six months
since his stroke and he wants others to
be aware so they can take the right
course of action to limit the damage
it's the scariest thing in the world you
don't really think it's ever going to
happen to you it always happens to other
people but when it happens to you is uh
you don't wish this on your worst enemy
now the faster you get to the hospital
when experiencing a stroke the less
likely you are to have lasting side
effects the main symptoms of a stroke
include numbness in the face or arms
trouble speaking or seeing headaches and
dizziness